hello everybody and especially hello to
my academic colleagues for whom this
video is being produced
I'm Greg Sadler I have a youtube channel
that I've been uploading content in and
using for my classes for about the last
nine years and I know that there's a lot
of people who don't have a lot of
background with video production and are
now in the situation of having to decide
what do I do
as I move all of my face-to-face classes
to online format and there is the 8 you
know the synchronous things that you can
do with with zoom and other video
conferencing platforms and that's great
I'm not saying don't do that that's
wonderful sort of stuff but you might
also want to create asynchronous
learning opportunities for your students
by shooting videos and that's what this
video is about it's to try to provide
some basic information and tips and
things that you want to keep in mind and
also some encouragement for those who
might find the task a little daunting
and what's the task making videos for
your students to substitute for the
face-to-face education that isn't taking
place so I'm gonna talk about what some
of the typical pain points and worries
and confusions are this is a really
basic video I'm not gonna go super into
depth about a lot of things you can ask
me things in the comments and perhaps
I'll shoot some other videos on specific
things down the line but this is for
doing bare bone video production so
that's that's going to be the core of
what we're doing here
before we get into the nuts and bolts
about video production and planning and
all those sorts of things that you might
be really worried about let's take a bit
of time to address some very basic
concerns just to add a little bit of
perhaps confidence or confirmation the
number one question that I think is on
most of my colleagues Minds we haven't
yet produced videos is is this something
I can actually do and the answer is
unequivocably
yes that you know you can produce good
lecture videos that will be effective
means of Education and you know
be helpful for your students and that's
what really counts doesn't matter
whether they have bells and whistles if
they're high production so long as they
get the content across that's what's
being expected of you you're not being
expected to produce a high quality
online class that would you know pass a
quality matters standards you are
expected in a crisis to move your
classes online and provide online
instruction and lecture videos are a
very good way of doing that so nobody is
gonna be holding you accountable for
arms and eyes or the lighting not being
right or the sound not being perfect or
anything along those lines it won't be
the students who are gonna be very
grateful for you doing this it won't be
your fellow instructors it won't be
administrators so that's one thing you
can put aside right away another basic
worry that you might have is our
students actually gonna watch the videos
and the answer is yes students do in
fact really value having good content
videos in online education which is now
what all of you are getting sort of a
baptism by fire in so that that's
another thing one last thing that I
thought I'd point out everybody knows
that you're working from home you don't
need a fancy studio I issued a lot of my
videos in front of this track board so
you may have seen some of them
or sitting in front of the Mac that's
right next to me
I'm shooting this right now on my laptop
you you know the only thing that's
that's particularly fancy about it is
I'm using my nice blue Yeti microphone
but you don't need that sort of thing
you can record on your phone you can
record in a lot of different ways and
everybody knows that you're working
within conditions that are not ideal
every once in a while here my cat comes
in and out I don't have kids like that
guy with a the video - gonna run in and
out and be taken out but if that happens
to you that's a-ok nobody is expecting
the stuff that you do to be perfect
the first thing that we should talk
about is what you're actually going to
need for video production you notice I
change scene a little bit and that's
what I can do with this laptop it's kind
of nice you know there's my chalkboard
there's my editing station with our iMac
I shot a video earlier today for my
students and you know there's a lot of
different ways that you can shoot video
one thing that you can do is if you've
got a cell phone that's relatively new
like from the last three years and the
only reason I bring that up is because
you want to have enough memory to do it
you can actually record from your cell
phone you can you know just turn it on
and you know start recording with the
front facing camera you can hold it it's
gonna be a little less steady but that's
that's okay
nobody expects perfection you might want
to prop it in place right or have some
way of holding it there are tripods that
you can get but you know if you don't
have one already that may be a little
bit of an issue and so this is probably
sort of the bare bottom level of
recording you can also record as I'm
doing right now from the camera in your
laptop most of us have laptops or
desktop computers that now have cameras
front-facing we use them for Skype and
for all sorts of other things you can
use that and it's going to be decent
quality the recording that you're gonna
get in terms of sound from your computer
that'll vary a bit but nobody's again
expecting perfection you can get decent
quality sound out of a laptop you get
good quality sound out of a phone
desktops are quite good obviously if you
have a mic it's nice to use one but it's
not absolutely necessary then if you
want to get more sophisticated and for
right now I don't actually recommend
that you do that but if you want to get
more sophisticated you can always use an
actual camera this is the GoPro that I
use for many of my videos prior to that
I was
using a flip cam and you notice that's
not a very fancy camera you don't
actually need to use high-end equipment
to get good results that that will work
for your students so those are some of
the considerations the other things you
want to think about lighting right you
notice that I've got these desk lamps
that I use here I also within my studio
here we go though that's my lighting
stuff my gear and I got those from
Amazon you can get an entire kit for 50
bucks if I remember right my tripod
actually came from Amazon for
twenty-five dollars you don't have to
pay a lot to get decent equipment but
you do want to think about lighting and
if you don't have good lighting in your
place and again it doesn't have to be
perfect because you can also fix that in
the editing software think about natural
light think about using the windows that
you have just to create a situation in
which you can create you know produce
the videos that you want for your
students what else the only other thing
that I'll mention is that for my
recordings I also like to use a lapel
mic because you know if I'm in front of
the chalkboard other way you know the
further you are from the recording
device the more it's picking up
background sound so the this camera is a
kind of a noisy camera the GoPro noise
you're actually than the previous one so
I use this and and I you know record the
sound file and then I put it in during
the editing process which is a very easy
thing to do if you're if you're doing
any sort of videos that aren't using a
camera but say voiceover PowerPoint or
anything like that
obviously you're using the mic from your
computer and it will be good enough you
don't need anything super fancy for
creating course videos
one of the things that you want to think
about is the format of the videos that
you're going to use and you're not stuck
with just one format so it's not as if
you start doing voiceover powerpoints
that in order to make the class
consistent you have to stick with that
and never do anything else you can do
whatever works for you so there's almost
you could say a sort of hierarchy going
from the bottom all the way up in terms
of engagement for your videos and so
let's talk about some of the different
options voice over PowerPoint or if
you're using a Mac of course slides or
the Google equivalent as well will work
for you that is is sort of the the most
basic thing that you can do it's not
very engaging but it does provide you
know content for your students and they
get to hear your voice which is going to
be important for them another thing that
you might want to consider doing a
second format would be screen recording
and so like an Apple you would use
QuickTime for that office 365 for
Windows users has its own variation of
that if you have Camtasia you can do
that so you can show them you doing
something on the screen and talking over
that a lot of YouTube tutorials look
like that and so depending on what
you're teaching that might be a good way
to do things
another thing that I've done like with
my critical thinking videos in the past
is slides and you just you know print
and export the slides you can do it from
PowerPoint you can do it from from
whatever other format you're using and
you just drop them into your video
editor and then you can use your video
editor to do a picture in picture of you
in the bottom or maybe at the top going
over that the one thing you have to do
if you're going to use that format is
make sure your slide doesn't have
information that's getting blocked out
by your lovely face and you know the
image of you leading the students
through that I myself prefer to use
recorded videos like you're seeing right
now me talking into the camera or in
front of the Troc board
you can use all sorts of other things
we're going to get to that in a minute
instead of a chalkboard but that's
probably the most engaging for students
when they can actually see you their
instructor not just your face and not
just like a portion of your body but a
good bit of you moving around talking in
the way that you normally would students
do in fact really respond to the human
face and figure the one thing I would
avoid the you know and they were quite
popular years back so many of you
remember these those animated videos
where you put in text and then in a kind
of robot voice a pig and a rabbit talk
to each other not engaging at all
I wouldn't use those for students but
any of the other formats I think would
be quite useful for you
another format consideration that you're
probably going to want to have in mind
is where you're going to upload the
video once you've actually produced it
and there you've got a number of
different choices as an educator so one
thing is you can use your own personal
YouTube or Vimeo channel that's not a
bad thing to do not least because
YouTube will provide you with closed
captioning which can be useful for your
students who are hearing-impaired or
have other you know reasons for wanting
to see text and and it will provide them
with transcripts it's not a hundred
percent accurate accent sometimes trip
it up but it's it's you know decent and
it's gotten a lot better in recent years
many institutions if you're using Google
suite will already have a YouTube
channel right there created for you
within your institution so I have for
example a Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design YouTube channel which I use only
for that miwaukee Area Technical College
also does that so you probably have that
if your if your institution as Google
suite another similar thing would be
called Tura
and both of those who have the advantage
of again of being able to provide closed
caption and then you might also consider
directly uploading your video into
whatever course management system you're
using that's like blackboard or canvas
or Sakai or Moodle because all of them
can upload fairly short videos and you
know depending on the bandwidth maybe
even longer videos you want to check to
see what that is maybe talk to your IT
person or you know you can also find
that in the course management system the
one disadvantage of that is that you're
not going to get closed captioning now
you know in the middle of a crisis
people aren't going to be that concerned
about a DEA compliance but it is nice
for students to have that so you might
want to consider you know your
institutional YouTube or personal
YouTube or Kaltura or something along
those lines
let's talk now about the actual
production and I'm not going to go
through how to do the video editing
software or anything like that there's
all sorts of tutorials out there for you
I will say this there's a learning curve
for any one of them I use iMovie but
there's you know all sorts of other
variations any of them are fine for what
you're gonna be doing just expect it to
take a little while what I'm gonna talk
about now is more about the production
on the shooting site like what I'm doing
right now talking to you so the very
first thing that I want to point out is
you're doing video which means that you
can do multiple takes take the pressure
off of yourself you don't need to get it
right the first time I sometimes get in
front of the chalkboard and shoot for
three minutes of me starting out a video
and not being happy with how I started
it or losing my train of thought and
then I just you know start again one
thing you might want to consider doing
if you're shooting at all like that is
don't stop the camera just keep going
and do this put a wave for yourself so
you know that at that point in time you
had you know some sort of glitch or a
mistake or brain fart or whatever you're
going to call it and that that's where
you want to pick up from and that's
perfectly fine
that's what editing is for you can take
pauses if you need to take a 20-minute
break go ahead and do that you can take
the pressure off of yourself so that's
that's the very first thing that we want
to think about second is a lot of people
are worried do I need to like write out
an entire script before I start shooting
and you can do that I mean right now
what I'm doing with this video I've got
some notes here and I'm going off of
those notes most of my videos that I
produce i've got stuff on the chalkboard
I use it as a rough guide from my own
thinking but most of what I'm doing
whether I'm you know lecturing online or
going face-to-face or even providing
lectures you know the pain lectures here
and there is going off of notes at most
or sometimes just what's in my head
that's me
a lot of you can do that probably more
of you than you think can but some
people might want to have a script and
it's perfectly fine to use a script as a
matter of fact if that makes you feel
more confident do that because that's
going to produce higher-quality video in
terms of content for your students and
that's what everything here is about
another thing that I think is really
helpful as you're either you know
scripting it or thinking out what you're
gonna say is anticipating where the pain
points for your students are where are
they going to get confused what
terminology is gonna trip them up what
questions are they likely to have you
might actually reserve some time at the
end of the video and you could like you
know again just take a pause and then
come back to that for likely questions
so you know when I'm shooting a video
for example on Kant's categorical
imperative the first formulation man
students are gonna get that mixed up and
so when I do a video on it I need to
think about okay how are they going to
go astray and how can I explain that to
them and you can do that in your own
field that you're the expert you
understand those things and presumably
you have some experience in seeing where
students are gonna need a little bit of
extra help so you can build that into
your video a few other things that I
would say you know you can use a
blackboard if you want to I'm kind of
old school that way some people like to
use a whiteboard or a flip chart one of
those paper things you flip over any of
those are perfectly fine you don't have
to have that though you could also
provide them with a write-up of your
video or slides if there's some content
that you want them to have it doesn't
all have to be in there in every single
part of the video it's a-okay
to do it with you know what works for
you and what you think your students
need the last thing that I'm going to
say about the actual production part and
this is very important
sometimes educators buy into this this
thing that went around it's essentially
a meme
among educational experts that we call
the five-minute rule
the idea was that videos in order to
engage the you know somewhat attention
deprived and and technology oriented
students of that then as I'm the future
because this has been said for twenty
years videos have to be only five
minutes long that is complete nonsense
students and other people will watch an
hour-long video if the content is really
good and engaging now I'm not saying
shoot an hour-long video I would say the
sweet spot is between 10 and 20 minutes
shorter videos can be useful but you
can't convey as much information now can
you think about if I decided to make
this only 5 minutes how much you'd be
missing out on all right it's perfectly
fine for you to shoot videos that are 10
minutes 15 minutes 20 minutes
you know half an hour all of those they
will work for your students students can
always take a pause when they want to
the key is the content has to be
interesting engaging worth watching and
again you're the experts so you can
figure out how to make your content fit
that bill I know that I have videos that
are an hour and a half long and people
watch them from the beginning all the
way to the end not everybody does of
course and I wouldn't suggest using
those four classes necessarily but
people will do that so you can dispense
with any worries about the five-minute
rule all of these things are worth
keeping in mind I said that that was the
last thing but I will say one other
thing in your videos don't try to be
somebody else your students already know
you as their instructor that they've
seen face to face for a while
just be yourself be conversational it
doesn't have to be perfect you are the
person that they are tuning in to help
them with whatever it is that you're
studying in that class so just keep that
in mind and the students will watch it
and be very grateful that you created
that material for them
once you've created your videos they
have to have a place to go a home to
live and that is most likely going to be
the course management system that you're
using for your now online course so it
could be blackboard Sakai moodle
desire2learn canvas Schoology all of
them and there's there's many others as
well you'll only need to know one of
them and that's the one that you're
putting things into and each of them has
a way to incorporate videos so if you
like put your videos into YouTube or the
institutional YouTube channel there's a
link and there's also an embed code and
you want to get familiar with how to
find those and you'll be able to put
those into the course management system
and you don't have to get fancy with it
you don't have to you know create you
know long sequences that are perfect or
anything like that you just have to have
your students able to access them so
even just writing the name of the video
and then the you know the link that is
perfectly fine so long as students can
access it there are probably tutorials
for any one of the systems that you're
using that can help you if you want to
embed it you know so they can see the
video playing within the system you can
also contact your campus IT departments
even though campuses are closed they are
still providing at least in most cases
some guidance and help you know for
people that are now trying to get fully
online the last thing that I do want to
say about this and I should have
mentioned this a little bit earlier this
can be a good sign you know you can
always switch things up in a video make
sure when you're uploading your videos
whether it's you know in in YouTube or
an institutional YouTube or directly
into the course management system make
sure that you have an accurate title you
don't have to worry so much about having
a nice thumbnail or anything like that
because you're not worried about search
engine optimization or getting lots of
views
you're worried about your students
understanding what the video is about so
those are the things that have to do
with with you know you might say the
implementation the incorporation of
videos into the actual class that you're
working on the last thing that I'll say
when you post new video content maybe
send out a message to your students
saying hey there's some videos for you
to check out because you know students
are going to need reminders from time to
time
I think there's a lot of common concerns
and worries that that first-time video
producers now perhaps in many cases
first-time online teachers will have
about this whole process and so you know
at the end of this video I want to take
a little time to try to allay some fears
and anxieties if possible based on my
experience and on what the research
tells us about you know lecture capture
video production all those sorts of
things so the first question that you
can ask yourself and probably a lot of
you envisioning shooting videos have
already done this and perhaps some of
you engage in some negative self-talk
about this is the video I'm gonna
produce or the videos that I'm going to
produce is it good enough and the answer
in almost every case is gonna be yes it
is good enough because you've all heard
that that phrase from back in the you
know early days of the internet content
is king content matters the most are you
able to convey information effectively
to your students good everything else is
gravy if it sounds great that's that's
great you want it to sound at least good
enough that students can make out what's
being said but if there's a little bit
of background hiss nobody's gonna ding
you on that does the lighting have to be
perfect absolutely not
you know so long as they can actually
see you or see the track board or
whatever it else it is that you're using
so long as the slides you know if you're
if you're doing PowerPoint stuff look
decent they don't have to be fancy it's
good enough so you're just doing the
basic bare-bones later on if you really
like doing this you can get more
advanced but right now what's important
is producing content for your students
so that they they can wrap their heads
around the the things that you're
studying in your class after the
disruptions that we're experiencing and
through a time of crisis so good enough
is good enough another key thing I would
say I mentioned you know being yourself
your students already have a rapport
or with you you don't need to think
about you know shooting videos that are
gonna somehow connect you to viewers
that have never seen you you're talking
to your students so not only should you
you know be yourself but you can expect
them to already relate to you you can
refer to things that you did before in
class and and you can use videos to kind
of build a sense of community students
are not going to be upset with you for
doing videos they are gonna be happy and
grateful that you're actually taking the
time to prepare materials for them that
lets them see a human face and voice
somebody who's concerned about them both
their health and their education so you
know smile you know we are in the middle
of a crisis but that doesn't mean that
you know everything has to be doom and
gloom at least in videos and you know
you might begin your videos this is a
suggestion from my wife who's always got
great advice about this you might
express some hopes that they're doing
well and you might close on something
like that as well another concern I
think that that some people have is
worries about being judged or evaluated
on the basis of their videos nobody is
going to be judging you or evaluating
you you know not not students not
administrators again we're in the middle
of a crisis the key is to make education
possible and to do so you know in an
engaging manner a well informed manner
it doesn't have to be highly produced if
you if you say um and AH like I do all
the time nobody is gonna hold that
against you this is for classes this is
not stuff that you're putting out there
on the internet for everybody
particularly trolls to go after you on
the last thing that I'll say in this
this this part is one thing to watch out
for is you know as you get excited about
the material that you're talking about
there is a human tendency to start
talking faster and faster and faster
that also happens when we're nervous or
anxious so you know
to pace your delivery a bit you know you
don't have to worry over much about what
you're wearing I mean if you want to
like dress up for class you certainly
can but there's no inherent necessity so
hopefully this has been helpful for you
has given you some ideas about how you
would go on and produce videos it's
gonna be a different sort of set of
processes for everybody because you've
got different software and hardware and
different material that you're
presenting but the basics are the same
you find something that works for you
whether it's an iPhone your computer's
camera another camera you try to make
sure that it's decent enough you know
picture and sound quality and lighting
but it doesn't have to be perfect and
you teach you teach your material you
teach it to your students you don't have
to worry about trying to pack it all in
in five minutes
dispense with that nonsense five minutes
rule it can be ten minutes twenty
minutes you know you can upload it to in
a lot of different ways you can edit it
in a lot of different ways if it's not
perfect if it's not beautiful that's
okay what matters is getting it done and
you've got lots of opportunities because
of the way video processing works to do
it you know multiple takes if you want
to if you're not happy with the first
take do it again
you're gonna get better and better at
this as time goes on there's a learning
curve so I encourage all of you to jump
in you can ask me questions in the
comments and I'll be happy to address
them and you know we'll see about maybe
shooting some other videos that are a
little bit more focused about particular
issues you know like why you would pick
this format or that format but but for
now just start start earning away and
see whether you can get some things out
there for your students you know maybe
by the end of the week
you